- [Narrator] This is Charlie Hall.
- Hi, I'm Charlie Hall.
- [Narrator] This is
Charlie Hall's kitchen.
- I make a fabulous cup of coffee.
- [Narrator] This is
where Charlie Hall sleeps.
- This is it, the waterbed.
- [Narrator] And that bed
is whole reason we're here.
- [Charlie] It's sensuous.
It's like taking your bed to bed with you.
- [Narrator] Charlie
Hall invented waterbeds.
- I currently own three waterbeds.
- [Narrator] Charlie
created a counterculture
alternative back in the ’70s.
- Remember the ‘70s and fern bars?
It was like, for the groovy people.
All right, you're too young for fern bars.
- [Narrator] In the ’80s,
they were as mainstream as they can get.
- [Charlie] You could walk into any store
in America and buy a waterbed.
How groovy is that?
- [Narrator] At their peak,
more than one in five of
the beds sold in the United
States were filled with water.
But it all started with
a novel idea Charlie had
when he was in grad school
in the late ‘60s.
He had an assignment to analyze
and improve human comfort.
- [Charlie] So, I talked to
physical therapists and doctors
and a whirlpool bath came up
as a frequently mentioned item
about a soothing temperature and water.
- [Narrator] Charlie's first prototype
was a chair filed with Jell-O,
but there was a problem.
- [Charlie] That was 300 pounds
and not terribly practical
around your living room
unless you had a forklift.
- [Narrator] So Charlie switched
gears and focused on beds.
- [Charlie] The bed evolved
into a water-filled chamber.
I discovered very quickly you needed
to compensate for the temperature.
- [Narrator] So he added
temperature control.
And when he showed the
assignment to the class.
- [Charlie] Everybody loved it
and they couldn't get enough of it.
- [Narrator] And guess what?
Charlie got an A.
- The original waterbed patent.
I applied for a patent shortly
after I developed the product
and I got a sense it
was gonna be a success.
- [Narrator] Charlie is still
a self-proclaimed water man.
This is Charlie's view.
This is his boat,
and this is Charlie with
his latest invention.
- [Charlie] Inflatable kayaks
that store in the trunk of your car
and paddle like a real, nice boat.
- [Narrator] Okay, that's great.
Back to waterbeds.
- [Charlie] The second coming is upon us.
The new version will blow the
old waterbed out of the water.
- [Narrator] Pun intended?
- Yes, pun intended.
(water rushing)